uh
luca just got a technical he's been
ejected with 31 seconds to go and luca
just got his 15th technical of the year
two tonight
he'll be suspended for a game if he gets
one more technical
in the remainder of the regular season
except for the last game of the regular
season
unless some of these technicals get
rescinded which could happen
he's had one rescinded this year for
what happened up in new york when he
yelled and one
[Applause]
moments like this are frustration when
you lose to a team again
you feel like you should not have lost
to
a couple of free throws for the
technicals one on rick one on
[Applause]
luca
so lucas walking over to the table
field goes one of two at the line on the
two technical foul free throws can we
see what happens here
[Applause]
i don't understand what happened there
and given the stakes and given what
happens based on number of technical
fouls
that one's going to be one that i'm sure
is going to be argued by the mouse and
a technical rescinded
i kind of speechless on that last one i
don't understand what